[Aplausos]
cuántos de ustedes se acuerdan de cuando
tenían tres años
cuántos de ustedes se acuerdan de ese
sentido curioso que les hacía que debe
explorar todo lo que les rodea
bien también se cuelan ok
pero no creo que se acuerden de cuándo
fue que perdieron ese sentido curioso
pues cuando somos pequeños la palabra
que más escuchamos es no niño no corras
niño no toques niño no brinque es bla
bla bla bla bla eso hace que comencemos
a perder un poquito de ese sentido
curioso y sin sumarle que aparte en la
escuela nos imponen esos típicos
estereotipos como que marianita es la
güerita o que juanito es el burro o que
juanita es muy rápida y por eso ella
siempre es buena en educación física
y aparte de que la maestra siempre te
tiene que regañar porque color y hasta
el perro rojo o porque te saliste de la
raya o porque quisiste colorear el cielo
morado porque dice que está mal pero
pues qué tal si tú no estás coloreando
la tierra y estás coloreando en el
planeta brilloso del arco iris y ahí
todos los perros son rojos y el cielo es
morado pero bueno pues siempre nos dicen
que está mal y eso hace que poco a poco
vayamos perdiendo ese sentido creativo
que todos tenemos esto de seguro les
pasó a todos ustedes ya mí también me
pasó
a la edad de los 12 años cuando estaba a
punto de salir de la primaria mis padres
tomaron una decisión muy difícil
la cual era sacarme de la escuela o sea
ya no entrar a la secundaria
y al principio pues estaba desconcertada
decía oh no
qué voy a hacer me voy a quedar sin
amigos voy a hacer una burra y por eso
no voy a tener triunfos en la vida qué
voy a hacer
y aparte no era la única que estaba
desconcertada también todos los amigos y
familiares y cualquier persona que
quisiera opinaba sobre ello y todos se
iban por el tema de la socialización
que no va a tener amigos
que no va a vivir lo que hacen los de su
edad
y antisocial
tengo mis amigos son pocos pero todos
valen la pena
y si fuera recaída y antisocial creo que
no estaría parada con ustedes justo
ahora pues cada uno de nosotros es
diferente pero hay ciertas cosas que nos
pueden ayudar a recuperar ese sentido
curioso que todos tenemos y ahora les
diré cómo
primero tienen que tener la audacia para
salirse de la raya sin tener miedo de
que la maestra los vaya a regañar
segundo busquen pasatiempos
probablemente encuentren un talento
oculto que no sabía que que no sabían
que tenían
vivan su vida al máximo y sabor y en día
tras día volví en su vida a ustedes para
que cada día sea un día mejor y lo
disfruten siempre y por último
descubre en su entorno como los niños
que son
jueguen brincan corran desde pequeños
nosotros estamos acostumbrados a seguir
un mismo método nos enseñan a tener
tareas horarios disciplina no estoy
diciendo que eso esté mal
pero
hay veces que estar siguiendo un mismo
método por mucho tiempo creo que no
puede ser muy bueno
sólo piénsenlo así son tres años de
kinder 6 de primaria y tres de
secundaria otros tres de bachillerato y
sin sumarle los años de la carrera son
aproximadamente
15 años de nuestra vida
el mismo método toda una vida
o bueno por lo menos para mí porque esos
son los años que llevo viviendo en este
planeta
se supone que la escuela nos enseñan las
bases a leer a escribir todo aquello que
nos va enseñando a cómo ganarnos la vida
para el día que lleguemos a la vida real
y otra parte cuando ya salimos de ese
método que estamos tan acostumbrados al
que llamamos escuela estamos tan
desesperados y tan nerviosos que nos
vamos rápidamente a buscar otro método
que llamamos empleo
con el cual se supone que nos vamos a
ganar la vida ahí es cuando yo les
pregunto a todos ustedes
si pasamos una parte de nuestra vida
aprendiendo a como ganarnos la vida y la
otra parte tratando de ganarnos la vida
entonces yo digo aquí cuando te ganas la
vida
salgan de la raya
[Aplausos]